World joining us now former Justice
secretary Sir Robert Buckland hi good
morning thanks for joining us thank you
what up on that do you think that KIA
estarma should be taking money from just
stop somebody who supports just stuff
oil no I don't I think that uh the
adjust top oil protesters cross a line
between legitimate freedom of speech and
freedom of expression which this country
is renowned for and the sort of behavior
that really disrupts the lives of the
rest of us uh and we've seen in recent
weeks how people have in effect quite
visibly taken matters into their own
hands now I don't think that's
advisable I think we should allow the
police to get on with the job that they
are there to do but one can understand
the frustrations that people have they
want to get on with their daily lives
they've got commitments sometimes very
serious commitments to see loved ones in
hospital for example being disrupted in
a way that I think most of us find
unacceptable and therefore you know if
this legally opposition aspires to be a
responsible leader and a prime minister
of this country then I think
associations of that nature picture
really perhaps tell a different story
which I think might lead to the
conclusion that frankly they're not
ready to govern yeah so just to clarify
um on that story just stop oil is
supported by a guy called Dale Vince
who's in charge of ecotricity who's also
given one and a half million pounds to
the labor party just to clarify that yes
talk to me
um about Rishi sunak um he is claiming
success over the drop in a recent
migrant Crossings is it up to his is it
down to his policies or is it because of
the weather well I think that the big
intervention that he made late last year
was getting that deal with Albania to
get back to Albania those individuals
who are crossing here uh unlawfully and
many people in our prisons as well who
we needed to repatriate that deal
clearly is working the number of
albanians has dropped I think by about
90 percent uh there has been a slight
change some other different
nationalities coming across but the
overall figure to June is about 20 down
on where it was last year so I think
that um he can claim legitimate credit
for the direct practical measures that
he's been taking in the last few months
and I think he deserves some praise for
that so why is that not why is he not
managing to get that message across
because a recent poll says 50 of people
think the government's doing a bad job
well I I think that the history of this
has been very very difficult and
governments of different colors have had
to deal with various manifestations all
of migrancy and Refugee status and I
think the public understandably is
somewhat cynical when they look at the
figures and think well it's all very
well having laws but if they're not
enforced then what does all of this add
up to and therefore what we have to do
is demonstrate by actions and by results
that things can be turned around you
know remember a few years ago okay the
channel tunnel was a real nightmare in
terms of security and people trying to
get in that problem was solved by
Britain and France you know I was on the
channel last week and there was no
question that it wasn't anything other
than a secure way through now we did the
same with lorries remember the terrible
business with lorries a few years ago
where people were dying in the backs of
lorries that problem was dealt with the
small boats is a if you like a reaction
the next stage in which unscrupulous
people try and find a way through to
this country we've just got to be very
very practically minded about this
working closely with the French to
deepen and improve the relation ship we
have with them on this and to and to
take that International action that the
Prime Minister quite rightly is leading
I love the fact that you called it the
channel you're showing your age
um it's highly likely that the
government will lose their legal action
against the covid uh inquiry so why are
they doing it well I I have asked that
question that Carlos Commons yesterday I
did ask that question I think it would
have been far better for lawyers on both
sides to agree uh what should be
relevant and used in the inquiry these
aren't items that should find themselves
into the public domain unless there's a
a clear relevance to them and that they
form the basis of decisions by baroness
Hallett uh you know I don't see why
we've ended up in this standoff bearing
in mind the fact the inquiry is going to
take a long time and all that this does
is prolong matters further I'm totally
going to hear the cases early as next
week which I think is encouraging but
you know I do ask the question what was
this really necessary bearing in mind
like I say the government's got
something to hide well I can understand
that sentiment I think to be fair to the
government what they're asking about is
the the the breadth by which the chair
of the inquiry uh has in which to
operate you know does she have this
unlimited set up the inquiry well indeed
and the law says that it is for the
chair to determine what is relevant now
unless they can show that the chair's
got it really badly wrong and that's
somehow she's doing some massive fishing
Expedition then I think they're they're
up against it should be allowed to have
whatever she wants like with the chill
cut inquiry well I think that if the
chair is true to the terms of reference
the terms of reference are very wide
when you look at them then I think she's
entitled to make an informed judgment
about what she regards as relevance and
I think that to challenge it in this way
potentially risks undermining the chair
and her discretion and created a
necessary standoff which as you say
gives the impression that somehow the
government has something to hide I mean
the government continues to goes you
know thousands of documents to the
inquiries they should do but I just
think this particular
approach doesn't help anybody far better
to get around the table agree what is
relevant and let the inquiry get on with
its job at the cabinet office Minister
Jeremy Quinn addressing Parliament
yesterday as as you know said all
relevant material has and will be
provided to the covid inquiry is it not
up to barnos outlet to decide what's
relevant well the law clearly says the
inquiries act which forms the basis of
this inquiry clearly says that it is for
the chair to determine what is relevant
the government is saying that a lot of
the material is
clearly or manifestly or unambiguously
irrelevant now well I I think that uh
you know bearing in mind the clear
wording of that uh statute that law then
it would be far better to defer to the
chair of the inquiry yes to make
reasonable points about you know the
terms of reference and sticking true to
the terms of reference but to launch a
legal challenge I I thought was
unnecessary and it would have been far
better to negotiate and deal with this
in a way that I think would have
respected the discretion of the chair
um chair of the bereaved families group
says if she doesn't get everything that
she's asking for that she has no
alternative but to resign do you agree
well I can understand what why that's
being said would you agree well I I
still think that it is there is time
here for the government to acknowledge
the fact that this was unnecessary that
it is for the chair to decide what is
relevant I certainly wouldn't want to
see baroness Hallett depart I think
she's been an outstanding lawyer and
public servant for many years well
respected and I think she's doing an
excellent job and therefore I think the
government need to be mindful of this
that we we shouldn't be putting the
government shouldn't be putting the
chair of the independent inquiry into
into a difficult position uh there are
now more independent MPS than sitting
lib Dem MPS
um should Bob Stewart join them
well without knowing the full facts as
to why but in the meantime until we do
understand that I I think the teacher
case really stands or falls on its own
merits I think that
um uh Mr Stewart's case is coming up
very quickly
um I I'm not going to pass a glib
judgment as to whether he should be an
independent MP
um
well
I think it depends on each individual
fat I mean if you strip things back to
you know MPS perhaps falling forward of
the law I mean obviously I think
speeding matters although you know there
can be significant apps fall into a
different category I'm not sure this
falls into the same category as perhaps
some of the other uh um you know in
alleged infringements that have resulted
in losing the whip I don't think it
brings any wider implications for Safety
and Security in Westminster in the
working place and therefore I think that
um I could understand why Lester whips
change their mind that at this stage
there is no need to to change Mr Stew's
status as a conservative MP so Robert
always a pleasure thanks for joining us
thank you thank